the General Affairs Council will focus
on preparations for the next summit of
EU leaders in Brussels with climate and
energy set to top the agenda the main
objective of the summit the European
Council is to reach agreement on the
outlines of the EU climate and energy
policy through to the year 2030 the
Union stands at the forefront of
international efforts to combat global
warming the policy will address
greenhouse gas emissions targets the
state of the emissions trading system
energy efficiency renewable energy
sources and energy security the leaders
will also discuss the state of the
economy based on a presentation by the
European Commission and preliminary work
completed in this General Affairs
Council issues of international concern
like the Ebola crisis unlikely to be
debated in a follow-up to the last
summit of EU leaders in June the
ministers will also exchanged views on
the topics of freedom security and
justice at this General Affairs Council
in Luxembourg